est-ce que tout va bien
ça me plaît parce que je vois là
il arrive vite
et merc alabama nous sommes un cargo non
armés nous avons deux esquifs on
approche chargé d'assaillants armés
possible leur être pire at il reçu
alabama mettez l'équipage en alerte et
préparer les lances à incendie ouais et
c'est tout ce doit être des pêcheurs
tout simplement ils sont pas là pour le
poisson
une circuit ouvrez les lances à l'armure
elle n est pas un exercice
pourquoi qu'ils accrochent cette échelle
30° bâbord
écoutez moi
nous avons des pirates armés à bord
s'il vous trouve souvenez vous vous
connaissez le bateau parle
restez unis et on s'en sortira
on ne sait pas lequel
tuez-moi village touma l'hébergement
d'accord regardons la corse et moi les
capitaines
capitalisme au bond et capitaine
phillips est ce que vous entendez